hemos normalizado vivir en un mundo de
prisa ante esta normalidad es muy común
ser indiferentes ser indiferentes a
situaciones tan elementales como pasarse
un alto como estacionar nuestro vehículo
en la entrada de nuestro vecino por qué
no estacionar lo en un lugar para
discapacitados
somos tan indiferentes que también
podemos pagar un mocho para poder entrar
al antro aunque no tengamos la edad
también podemos pagar ese mismo moche
para que nadie nos venga a inspeccionar
porque además de que somos indiferentes
también somos un tantito corruptos
corruptos y corruptas
pero no solamente somos indiferentes
ante esos pequeños detalles también
podemos ser indiferentes ante otras
situaciones anti situaciones tan
elementales como lo es reconocernos
conocernos estar cercanos
hoy es preferible que nos comuniquemos a
través de nuestros teléfonos celulares y
a través de estos teléfonos celulares
podemos decir las cosas que en realidad
son importantes podemos decir un te
quiero
podemos decir un lo siento y decir que
lo decimos de corazón también a través
de internet podemos perder la voluntad y
podemos por qué no compartir y volar el
pac el de nosotros o el de alguien más
grabar una escena íntima sexual tener
cibersexo porque además se vale y sin
voluntad compartirlo
ante eso también somos indiferentes
porque porque perdemos esta posibilidad
de distinguir este contacto cercano
perdemos la posibilidad de tocarnos de
decir que estamos unas y otros a un lado
soy norma pimentel abogada creyente
ocupada y preocupada también por esta
alta incidencia en la inseguridad de las
mujeres creyente de que podemos
transformar a la sociedad a través de la
cultura de la legalidad y de que vamos a
abrir caminos con la transparencia
les pido por favor a todas las mujeres
que se encuentran hoy aquí que se pongan
de pie
por favor observen a las que están en
frente a las que están detrás háganlo
háganlo obsérvense entre ustedes a las
que están al frente a las que están
detrás a las que están a su lado derecho
a su lado izquierdo
y ahora les pido que por favor entre
ustedes se tomen de la mano
les pido
muy bien muchas gracias les pido también
que observen y que se reconozcan que se
identifiquen ya los hombres que nos
están acompañando si alguno de ustedes
las conoce por favor hablen de por su
nombre nombre en las
si es que las conocen y si no
se quedan sin nombre
de acuerdo a las cifras internacionales
de onu-mujeres se indica que una de cada
tres mujeres
una de cada tres de ustedes una de cada
tres de nosotras de las que estamos hoy
aquí de pie sufrimos violencia física o
sexual por personas sumamente cercanas
de nosotras que pueden ser nuestras
parejas nuestros padres nuestros
hermanos nuestro círculo más cercano o
no mujeres también indica que para el
caso de méxico ser mujer
hoy es una pandemia rendir en nuestra
encuesta nacional del comportamiento
indica para 2016 que seis de cada diez
mujeres sufrimos algún tipo de violencia
eso significa que de las que estamos
aquí presentes estamos dentro de esa
incidencia yo les preguntaría si vamos a
ser indiferentes ante esto si mujeres y
hombres van a ser indiferentes ante esta
situación vamos a seguir sin poder
identificarnos sin hacer esto tocarnos
de las manos voltearnos conocernos y
reconocernos porque si vamos a seguir
siendo así de indiferentes entonces
pensaría que este país no tiene un
cambio pero yo soy un poco más optimista
y creo que si se pueden cambiar las
cosas
muchas gracias por favor pueden tomar
asiento
esta mañana quiero compartir con ustedes
tres aspectos que considero que son
fundamentales para poder cambiar esta
situación de inseguridad que afecta a
las mujeres en nuestro país y que las
afecta también en todo el mundo porque
miren este tema de ser misóginos
machistas y de replicar modelos y
estereotipos no solamente lo vivimos en
este país lo vivimos todas las mujeres
en todo el mundo el primer tema es este
específicamente hablar con ustedes de
qué son los derechos humanos y cómo a
través de los derechos humanos podemos
conocernos y reconocernos como personas
el segundo punto es compartirles mi
experiencia desde el enfoque de la
cultura de la legalidad y el tercer
punto es específico sobre el tema de la
creación de redes
hablar de los derechos humanos
implica conocer y reconocer que en esto
también vamos a un tanto atrás en la
indiferencia
una definición muy básica respecto de
qué son los derechos humanos indica que
tanto mujeres como hombres por el solo
hecho de ser personas de ser seres
humanos tenemos la posibilidad de
acceder a ellos pero yo les preguntaría
quién es de aquí se han dado a la tarea
de revisar qué dice la constitución al
respecto quiénes han checado al menos
los primeros 29 artículos de la
constitución quienes han checado al
menos la declaración universal de los
derechos del hombre del hombre
quien ha hecho una lista y ha
identificado cuáles son sus 10 derechos
humanos intransitables bueno 10 tal vez
son muchos sus 5 derechos humanos
bueno 5 también tal vez son muchos al
menos 3 yo les voy a decir mis 3
derechos humanos que son intransitables
que no toleraría que nadie pasará por
encima de ellos mi libertad mi igualdad
ante cualquier persona hombre o mujer
y el derecho fundamental de tener acceso
a la justicia esos son los míos mis
intransitables y esos intransitables
además tengo el compromiso de respetar
los con los terceros
pero bueno ahí les dejo la tarea ustedes
cuáles consideran que son sus derechos
humanos intransitables
pues no se preocupen miren la verdad es
que en la teoría también nos ha costado
ponernos un poquito de acuerdo
y resulta que en materia internacional
la declaración de los derechos del
hombre y de los derechos humanos perdón
establece cuáles son las características
de los mismos también los teóricos se
han preocupado en identificar la
distinción entre derechos humanos
garantías individuales y derechos
fundamentales otros teóricos lo que han
considerado que es importante es
identificar cómo hemos evolucionado como
sociedad y cómo hemos generado
diferentes etapas de los derechos
humanos una primera una segunda una
tercera y hay algunos que consideran que
la cuarta la quinta tal vez estaría
sujeta a debate pasamos de hablar de la
igualdad de la libertad de la necesidad
de tener un estado de derecho a hoy
reclamar que tenemos la posibilidad de
wifi gratis para todas y para todos en
este país
pero si tenemos todos estos avances en
la parte de la teoría si tenemos todos
estos avances en la creación de estos
documentos jurídicos yo me pregunto por
qué a nivel mundial no nos podemos poner
de acuerdo en algo tan elemental como el
derecho humano de todas las mujeres a
decidir sobre su cuerpo es algo tan
complicado sino la declaración universal
de los derechos humanos establece eso
que tienen que ser conceptos universales
porque no podemos partir de algo tan
elemental ponernos de acuerdo y saben yo
solita me voy a responder esta inquietud
creo que no podemos ponernos de acuerdo
porque ante todo eso ante toda esa
teoría también somos indiferentes pero
no somos indiferentes ante esto
y ojalá fuera para no discriminar ante
esto se nos hace mucho más fácil
discriminar ejemplos bastan y sobran
pero yo solo les preguntaría vemos esta
imagen y que nos genera algunos
incomodidad algunos molestia algunos tal
vez ni siquiera la quisieran mirar
pero qué pasaría si los viéramos y las
viéramos caminando así en la calle
tal vez algunos lanzaríamos un mensaje
lanzaríamos un tweet algunos otros
diríamos algún comentario inapropiado
pero no sintiéramos tal vez más cómodos
y no faltaría quien lanzara un golpe o
quien sin sintiera con la posibilidad de
arrebatarles la vida
y ante eso si no somos indiferentes
verdad porque discriminar no nos cuesta
trabajo
el siguiente punto que quiero compartir
con ustedes pues es la cultura de la
legalidad de ahí me siento sumamente
cómoda porque como dirían pues ese es mi
tema hablar de que a las abogadas y a
los abogados nos corresponde una
obligación fundamental acompañar a todas
las ciudadanas y ciudadanos en el
conocimiento y reconocimiento de sus
obligaciones y de sus derechos porque
está padrísimo hablar nada más de los
derechos no reconocer también cuáles son
nuestras obligaciones y entonces cuando
quiero reconocer cuáles son nuestras
obligaciones
resulta que en materia en lo específico
de violencia contra las mujeres se han
creado algunas políticas públicas con el
objetivo de fortalecer de sensibilizar
en realidad es necesario sensibilizar
ante la muerte de las mujeres
tal parece que si tal parece que la
chamba de las abogadas y de los abogados
es decir mira si te cela no te quiere si
te pide la clave del internet o te dice
que tienes que estarle indicando cuáles
son tus pasos a cada momento y que mejor
le hablas le abras la ubicación en
tiempo real de tu este gps pues sabes
que yo creo que no te quiere pero si
además de eso te humilla te menosprecia
te dice que tu espacio no es el público
que tu espacio es el privado si además
de eso se ha atrevido a golpearte
si además de eso se ha atrevido a
exigirte que tengan relaciones sexuales
sin tu consentimiento
créeme que lo que falta ese pequeño paso
para cometer un feminicidio no es
necesario que saquemos el código penal y
que le digamos todos los años todo lo
económico que tiene que reponer para
reparar el daño el tuyo y el de la
sociedad
en eso no podríamos ser indiferentes el
problema es que en la actualidad tal vez
ustedes han escuchado hablar de que
existe una figura jurídica única
creadora innovativa porque además méxico
se colocó a la vanguardia por tener una
legislación que incluye una figura que
se llama declaratoria de alerta de
violencia de género esa figura jurídica
que en la actualidad se encuentra
vigente dentro de 19 entidades
federativas esa figura jurídica que hoy
nos obliga a identificar cuáles son las
acciones de coordinación entre
federación estados y municipios que
además en el escenario de la cultura de
la legalidad genera responsabilidades
responsabilidades tan elementales como
decirle a la autoridad que investiga los
delitos que no puede permitir que una
mujer o que las familias de las víctimas
pasen más de 20 horas para poder ser
atendidas en una fiscalía una figura
jurídica que nos permite tener focos
rojos dentro de los municipios donde se
dan las condiciones de mayor de mayor
incidencia en contra de las mujeres
una figura jurídica que además hoy se
encuentra vigente dentro de 50
municipios de esta hermosa entidad eso
significa que en 50 municipios en
nuestro estado es pandémico ser mujer es
altamente peligroso ser mujer
y yo les preguntaría vamos a ser
indiferentes a esto
vamos a dejar de tocar las manos de las
mujeres que se encuentran cercanas de
nosotras
vamos a permitir que se replique en
estos escenarios donde se nos violenta
se nos culpabiliza porque la culpa no es
del violador la culpa es de la mujer por
cómo se vistió por lo que le dijo que lo
provocó
porque no aflojó
o porque no se quedó calladito y no se
vio más bonita
yo creo que no verdad yo creo que el
cambio va a venir de nosotros de que esa
indiferencia se acabe de que conozcamos
un poquito más de nuestro entorno de que
identifiquemos que efectivamente hoy en
mexico ser mujer es altamente peligroso
y el último punto que quiero compartir
con ustedes es algo que me emociona que
me hace sentir que efectivamente las
cosas van a cambiar y van a cambiar no
porque nos lo diga una ley no porque nos
lo diga una declaración internacional
van a cambiar porque nosotras y nosotros
mismos decidamos poner manos a la obra
porque decidamos dejar de ser
indiferentes
fíjense que hace algún tiempo
a mí misma me hice creer que tenía que
llegar a ser más fuerte que el silencio
que tenía básicamente que tragarme
muchas cosas y que tenía que aguantar
las yo sola que tenía que caminar yo
sola
porque estaba casi segura
que tenía que demostrarle al mundo que
norma pimentel podía ser más fuerte que
el silencio
sin embargo hubo un día
en el que fueron las palabras de mi hija
que está próxima a cumplir 15 años
en un momento de mucha confianza me dijo
mira mamá me encanta a lo que te dedicas
más al cine que antes defendiendo a
mujeres pero si tú no vas a venir a
defender a tus mujeres de tu casa
a mí y a ti misma y no vas a poner un
alto entonces estás completamente
equivocada porque estás haciendo justo
lo que le exiges a las autoridades
tú no estás siendo congruente tú estás
siendo indiferente
entonces me di cuenta que no podía ser
más fuerte que el silencio yo sola que
para poder ser fuertes lo primero que
tenemos que hacer es deconstruir nos y
volvernos a construir construir nos a
través de redes hoy precisamente son
estas redes de acompañamiento estas
redes de mujeres de mujeres y de hombres
que se comprometen justamente a no
dejarnos solas lo que hace la diferencia
acciones probó no acciones jurídicas
para decirle a las mujeres que no
estamos solas que siempre va a haber una
voz una persona alguien que nos va a
estar acompañando que nos va a estar
acompañando desde diferentes entornos
porque fíjense que lo más interesante es
que desde entornos empresariales
académicos jurídicos sociales
gubernamentales también hay espacios
donde las mujeres podemos sentirnos no
solamente sentirnos sino descubrirnos
que no estamos solas
y precisamente es en este acompañamiento
en el que yo les quiero dejar este
mensaje
espacios vamos a encontrar siempre
espacios para ser indiferentes para
discriminar para olvidarnos de cuáles
son nuestros aspectos fundamentales esos
que nadie ningún abogado nos tiene que
venir a decir porque miren lo bonito de
los derechos humanos es que son
inalienables y están tan próximos a
nosotros que lo único que tenemos que
hacer es dejar tantito a nuestro
teléfono en osh y ponernos nosotros en
onna entonces yo les quiero decir eso
les quiero pedir que recuerden este
pequeño ejercicio que hicimos donde nos
tomamos de la mano donde nos vimos donde
nos observamos y a los hombres que
estaban aquí pedirles que identifiquen
quiénes están cercanas y aprendan a
nombrarlas por su nombre porque es
sumamente triste desgarrador y
vergonzante
cuando las vemos nombradas en prensa
como un caso más de un feminicidio
les pido a usted
a todas y a todos les pido que no seamos
indiferentes porque si somos
indiferentes a ustedes a nosotras es
indiferencia nos mata muchísimas gracias
[Aplausos]